we have some good but potentially
temporary
news depending on who the next president
is and that news is that president joe
biden has
suspended drilling leases in the arctic
national wildlife refuge also known as
anwar
the decision blocks for now oil and gas
drilling in one of the largest tracts of
undeveloped wilderness
in the united states the biden
administration yesterday suspended oil
drilling leases in anwar unspooling a
signature achievement of the trump
presidency that's a good thing
and delivering on a promise by president
biden to protect the fragile alaskan
tundra
from fossil fuel extraction the decision
sets up a process that could halt
drilling in one of the largest tracts of
untouched wilderness in the u.s
home to migrating waterfowl caribou and
polar bears
but it also lies over as much as 11
billion barrels of oil
and democrats and republicans have
fought over whether to allow drilling
there for more than four decades
a former formal order from secretary
interior secretary deb halland
paused the leases until her agency has
completed an environmental analysis of
their impact
and a legal review of the trump
administration's
decision to grant them so
this is good this is this is what could
be done right now we're four months in
or
yeah four months in almost five four and
a half months into joe biden's
presidency
but this really needs to be made
permanent and and
the point that i keep going back to on
this is we we really don't need this
and of course you know the right wingers
the gas price will go up a tenth of a
cent again and they'll point to this i
actually
saw a comment on reddit which said
nothing like importing foreign oil at
increased rates just so that later we
can go and drill the very oil
that we are now protecting no one is
thinking long term
that is such a an incorrect
perspective the whole point here is
we should be moving away from oil
anybody who's saying
you know the goal for energy should be
let's keep pushing
even if it takes years to be drilling
in the arctic in the anwar refuge no no
no no
we we should be using this time during
which we actually already have plenty of
oil
to transition away from oil and i think
that
very often this debate gets into these
straw man arguments like
listen if you shut off oil today heat
indoor heating goes away we don't have
gasoline for vehicles we don't have this
we don't have that
i don't know who they're referring to
when they say that
but i've never met anyone serious on the
left who says we should be off oil today
i understand that if we there would be
no way to get off of oil today
but the whole point here is we should be
dramatically accelerating
solar power development oh but david
there's not you can't use solar power to
generate
well look at the efficiency increase
we've seen in solar
panels over the last 20 years and if we
get even half of the same
over the next 10 that goes a huge way
in combination with wind and geothermal
etc now
there is a real conversation to have
about nuclear i've said before
new nuclear is very very safe
i am not a reflexive anti-nuclear
activist very often and we've talked to
nuclear
uh engineers on the nuclear energy
engineers on the show
very often there's this reflexive oh but
look at look at chernobyl and look at
this stuff from from the 70s
the reality is that if we were to bring
on
new nuclear today with modern nuclear
technology
none of those things would be issues so
for me
i'm totally comfortable using new
nuclear as a stop gap what are the
concerns that i have with it number one
the disposal of the waste continues to
be an issue
um i don't know about
you know but there's people who say now
you just ship it you put it underground
it's fine
i'm just not sure about that i'm not
saying there isn't a solution
but that still remains a question for me
but really the bigger question for me
with saying
let's use nuclear as a way to be a
bridge
off of fossil fuels and onto alt real
renewables
um is that it seems to me we would get
addicted to nuclear
and it takes a while to bring new
nuclear technology online so
my concern would be if we say let's do
new nuclear
and it'll take eight years to bring some
of this online
by the time that it's online the fact
that we've been focusing on nuclear
might have diverted energy and attention
and funding
from get from real renewables and that
scares me but
in theory i am not against doing uh new
safe
nuclear as a stop gap um one other thing
there are people who who like to say the
sun's not really renewable you know
i mean we've got five to six billion
years of solar
okay that's if we by fi if the human
race survives that long
we can never be certain about anything
but i would be reasonably sure
that we would have moved somewhere where
the sun exploding in five to six billion
years
is not going to be uh what destroys the
human race so for all practical purposes
when we're talking about peak oil and
we're talking about
10 20 50 100 year timelines of what
we're doing to the planet with oil use
5 to six billion years of solar power
sounds pretty damn renewable to me all
right so good decision by joe biden
uh we'll follow it and of course there's
a bigger conversation here
about a bigger transition that needs to
take place